how exciting would it be to get a move
on a sequel while we've got even more
exciting news for you there are rumors
that Moana 2 will feature Disney's
first-ever Latina princess
keep watching to discover how their
paths might cross
Disney Princess sequels Disney princess
movie sequels are certainly something to
get excited about that is when they're
done on a grand scale we're not talking
about those straight-to-dvd follow-ups
that never live up to the originals
Belle Ariel jasmine Pocahontas
Cinderella and Mulan all have sequels
however they went directly to home
theater by Disney without a theatrical
run but with Moana - we're hoping for a
cinema release and a movie as good as
the first
[Music]
Moana to what we know so far all the
recent chatter about Moana 2 is down to
a specific quote it comes from
lin-manuel Miranda's father when Manuel
was the music co-writer for the original
Moana movie and it sounds like the
songwriter is getting ready to come up
with more tunes for Moana his father
Lewis told page six that lin-manuel is
talking to Disney about a sequel to
Moana Lewis added that the movie would
be about a Latina princess
it's that mention of a Latina princess
that has got so many fans even more
excited and that's because this Latina
princess would be a groundbreaking
character in the tradition of Disney
Princess films the history of Disney
princess diversity let's take a look
back at the evolution of the Disney
Princess franchise to understand just
how important this news is the early
Disney Princesses of the Golden Age era
were Snow White Cinderella and Aurora
then in the Renaissance era from around
1989 to 1999 we started to see some
cultural diversity after Ariel and Belle
came Pocahontas jasmine and Mulan those
three princesses all come from different
cultures and then in 2009 Tiana broke
new ground as the first ever
african-american Disney Princess
[Applause]
her movie The Princess and the Frog
started what's known as the Disney
revival era this was a period of time
when critics heralded the Disney studio
for returning to form with Moana in 2016
Disney introduced a Pacific Islander
princess so it makes sense that the
studio is continuing to represent
diverse cultures by introducing a Latina
princess next but she wouldn't actually
be the first one
oh nothing I'm sorry I was just having a
thing with Naomi what's up Disney's
current Latina princess anyone who loves
watching Disney TV shows knows that
there's already a Latina princess and
that's Elena of avalor who's TV series
debuted in 2016 in fact this Latina
princess has also crossed paths with
other Disney Princesses Elena's starred
in a special episode with Princess
Sophia from the Disney TV series Sofia
the first their hour-long crossover
episode was called Elena and the secret
of avalor and fans discovered that Elena
had been trapped inside Sofia's magical
amulet that could provide a clue as to
how Moana and the new Latina princess
might meet stay tuned for our theory on
that later but back to Moana two Latina
princess this new character would be the
first-ever Latina princess to star in a
Disney feature-length film and that
would be groundbreaking Disney has made
steps in the right direction with the
2017 movie Coco it was a big hit two
reportedly making five hundred million
dollars worldwide but we're wondering if
these two things Moana Tzu and the
Latina princess are actually going to
happen together or not we need to have a
closer look at the quotes from Lin
Manuel's father to untangle what's
really going on here his exact words
were that Lin Manuel is talking to
Disney about a sequel to Moana
but the movie would be about a Latina
princess so that would actually mean
that there is no crossover between the
two these could be two separate projects
one project could be the Mohana sequel
and another project could be a Latina
princess movie or there might not even
be another Moana movie by using the word
sequel he might well just mean follow-up
and that might mean
Manuel is following up his previous
Disney princess movie work with a new
Disney princess movie only this time it
will be a Latina princess which theory
do you think makes more sense a Moana
sequel that also features a Latina
princess or simply a new Disney animated
movie that stars a Latina princess
given that Moana made 643 million
dollars worldwide it makes sense that
Disney would want to do more with it so
let's assume there's going to be a Moana
- and let's have a little fun and
speculates how electing a princess might
feature in this movie anyone who's seen
wreck-it Ralph - Ralph breaks the
internet knows how comical it can be
when Disney Princesses meet up but how
would my wanna cross paths with this
princess we all know Moana loves the
wide ocean so it would totally make
sense that Moana would take a trip to
another Island and that Island could be
home to this new latina princess we
could also take inspiration from the way
Disney's TV Latina princess Elena of
avalor cross paths with princess Sofia
Elena was living inside Sofia's amulet
perhaps this new latina princess was
living inside Mona's heart of defeating
however it happens we cannot wait to see
it when could this happen
as of January 2019 lin-manuel is still
busy with Hamilton in Puerto Rico
raising money after the devastating
hurricane and he's also writing and
producing new songs for the live-action
remake of Little Mermaid
so although his plate is full at the
moment perhaps she's already scheduled
time for this latina princes movie
and/or a Moana sequel there's no
official comments from him or Disney yet
but surely his father is a reliable
source
we sure do hope so before you go let us
know in the comments what you think is
going to happen with this slated new
movie and weigh in with your own
theories about how mallanna could meet a
Latina princess in her sequel and that's
it please give this video a big thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to the
things thanks for watching
[Music]